putin gegen den westen die welt steht am
rande eines krieges und mitten in dieser
krise der nato chefs bei bild live hier
sehen wir in ankommen jens stoltenberg
hier gestern kann man am axel springer
haus und dann erreicht hier unsere
studios ja und dauer hat er der
nato-chef dann auch das wort krieg in
den mund genommen
grüße wie change es gibt eine echte
gefahr für neue militärische konflikte
in europa denn was wir sehen sind ganz
signifikante militärische bewegung von
russischer seite in der nähe von der
ukraine mit hunderttausenden von
soldaten mit schwerem gerät und schwerer
bewaffnung das kombiniert mit einer
bedrohlichen rhetorik aus russland und
wir kennen natürlich auch die politische
geschichte us genannt ist nämlich dass
auch in 2014 in russland schon
militärisch gewalt gegen die ukraine
angewendet hat und alles zusammen
genommen bedeutet das ist ein echtes
risiko darstellt es gibt eine echte
gefahr eines krieges in europa sagte der
nato-chef hierbei bild live darüber
sprechen wir zugeschaltet ist uns die
fdp verteidigungsexpertin marie agnes
strack zimmermann und der historiker
professor michael wolffsohn schönen
guten tag ihnen beiden guten morgen frau
strack-zimmermann wenn der nato-chef das
wort krieg in den mund was bedeutet das
ich begrüße dass er das so deutlich
ausspricht weil diese aggression seitens
russland der ukraine und damit dem
westen gegenüber ist eine
besorgniserregende situation und wir
sollten es nicht schön reden aber wir
sollten natürlich alles unternehmen
damit es eben nicht zu einem krieg kommt
die bedrohung ist ja auch so sichtbar
und auch danach zu wollen wir mit ihnen
gemeinsam einmal reinschauen da haben
wir den nato-generalsekretär befragt
das dürfen wir nicht vergessen dass der
russischen truppen zum teil auch an der
ukrainischen grenze stehen aber einige
von ihnen auch schon auf ukrainischem
gebiet sie sind auf der krim das ist
ein englisches gebiet das sind
historische grenzen russland mal an
anerkannt hätte und auch in dollars und
dem duo hans stehen sie das ist auch
precious gebiet wir reden also von
russischen truppen bewegungs in und nahe
der ukraine ja herr professor sondern
sie hören den nato-chef hierbei bilden
und sind drohungen aus moskau von putin
auch nichts neues aber über jahrzehnte
ja nichts neues gewesen wo stehen wir
wenn wir all diese drohungen der
vergangenen jahre der vergangenen
jahrzehnte mit der aktuellen situation
vergleichen
wir stehen vor einem scherbenhaufen und
der internationalen politik
diese scherbenhaufen ist
winterreise auch von der makro allianz
mit zu verantworten war in einem
zusammenbruch der sowjetunion im jahre
1991 und der an sich begrüßenswerte
neugründung von
nachfolgestaaten ihr im grunde genommen
wieder gründungen waren nicht
berücksichtigt wurden ist bieten die
bevölkerungspolitische zusammensetzung
in den jeweiligen staaten ist und dann
sind plötzlich die sache ganz anders aus
nehme ich die tatsache dass der osten wo
keines weitgehend von einer russisch
orientierten und russisch stämmigen
russisch sprechenden bevölkerung
gekennzeichnet ist und das gleiche gilt
für die creme wir haben also eine
absurde situation dass das völkerrecht
dass er den frieden eigentlich sichern
soll und sichern könnte im totalen
gegensatz steht zur bevölkerungs
politischen zusammensetzung und damit
auch zu den unterschiedlichen willen der
jeweiligen bevölkerungsgruppen und das
ist eine frage die gelöst werden muss
und insofern so schrecklich die
gegenwärtige situation ist diese
zuspitzung könnte eine chance sein für
eine friedliche
neuregelung auch der inneren
konstruktionen nicht nur von der ukraine
sondern von vielen randstaaten um das
gebiet russlands herum und deswegen
müssen wir eben nicht nur kurzfristig
schauen ist das hier eine kriegsgefahr
oder nicht ja es ist eine kriegsgefahr
aber die kriegsgefahr kann langfristig
und grundsätzlich nur überwunden werden
wenn eine neue sinnvolle politische
struktur aufgebaut wird
dennoch beobachtet die welt mit sorge
was wird passieren mit den panzern
rollen die einen in die ukraine morgen
übermorgen nächste woche nächsten monat
frau strack-zimmermann wie sollten wir
dann reagieren
also erst einmal sollten wir keine
panikattacken führen wenn ich das mal so
sagen darf ich möchte nicht dass heute
morgen menschen angst haben dass ihr
panzer rollen aber wir müssen einfach
zur kenntnis nehmen dass putin seit
monaten schon an der ostukrainischen
grenze eben truppen aufhört und zwar in
wirklich wie sie gerade sagten über
100.000 mann und das kann man natürlich
nicht unkommentiert lassen und wir
sollten auch nicht naiv sein putin wird
so lange druck auf den der ersten
ausüben wie er kann das ist historisch
in russland leider nichts neues und der
westen klar sein dass auch wenn die
ukraine nicht mitglied der nato ist dass
uns ein möglicher angriff oder eine
mögliche aggression ich nenne es mal so
ganz europa tangiert es gibt eine
europäische sicherheitsstruktur er hat
sich bewährt den frieden gebracht in den
letzten 30 jahren und es ist schon ein
wenig verrückt wenn ich das sagen darf
dass putin mit dem feuer spielt das
narrativ jetzt aufkommen dass wir doch
bitte dafür sorge zu tragen hätten dass
er sich nicht die finger verbrennt das
heißt nicht der westen ist aggressiv
nicht die ukraine ist aggressiv sondern
russland und ich bin zutiefst überzeugt
davon dass macht übrigens die
außenministerin sehr gut dass man
russland klar machen muss dass dieses
große folgen haben wird vor allem
wirtschaftlicher natur wir dürfen nicht
vergessen russlands bruttoinlandsprodukt
bei über 120 millionen einwohnern ist so
groß wie das von italien was halb so
groß ist das wirtschaftlich ist russland
nicht im entferntesten so stark wie es
militärisch ist und insofern müssen wir
russland bzw putin denn das russische
volk leidet
putin at große probleme dass putin klar
sein muss dass das ganze auch
wirtschaftliche folgen stehen hat und
dass er sich ein problem ein handelt und
wenn sie mir noch einsatz erlauben das
ist ja interessant was gerade passiert
putin habe sorge dass die ukraine sich
den besten andockt und
er sollte sich mal umdrehen da sind noch
die bündnis neutralen staaten wie
finnland und schweden finnland hat eine
über
1300 lange kilometer lange grenze mit
russland wie immer bündnis neutral waren
und dies jetzt darüber eine diskussion
führen ob sie nicht doch der nato
beitreten weil sie eben sorge haben nach
sehr russland eben auch mal den finnen
gegenüber so auftreten könnte das heißt
dass europa ist aufgeweckt das ist die
gute nachricht und es wird zeit dass die
europäer da auch mit einem wort sprechen
herr professor wolf so ein patricia
platini hat schon die frage gestellt was
passiert denn wenn ich das ist ja eine
ganz entscheidende frage vor allen
dingen in der rechnung von wladimir
putin aktuell der das natürlich aus
testet was passiert wenn ich das und das
mache wie reagiert der westen wie
reagiert die eu wie reagiert die nato
noch mal ganz konkret wir hören immer
ökonomische konsequenzen das ist das
auch was der nato-chef gestern in den
vordergrund gestellt hat neben der hilfe
über ja waffenlieferung militärisches
gerät geliefert aber was passiert wenn
tatsächlich die panzer die direkt an der
grenze stehen von der ukraine nach
russland beziehungsweise andersrum wenn
die tatsächlich über die grenze rollen
wie reagieren wir
wortreich aber
nicht taten weich und natürlich muss man
da ganz nüchtern betrachten wenn bis der
westen mit diesem aufmarsch rein
militärisch fertig werden könnte das
wird sehr lange dauern
also es wird viel aufregung geben und
viel worte aber keine taten korpi es
wird wirtschaftliche sanktionen geben
frau zimmermann hat das völlig zurecht
erwähnt aber die leidens bevölkerung die
der leidensdruck die leidensfähigkeit
der russischen bevölkerung ist erheblich
größer bei uns im westen auch wir sind
abhängig von russland
gaspipeline nord stream zwei es gibt ja
auch noch zum 1 das könnte also auch
dann
zugemacht werden von russland gewiss der
verlust für russland wäre immens aber
die leidensfähigkeit der russischen
bevölkerung natürlich auch gezwungen
durch putin jährlich größer der
innenpolitische druck in deutschland und
europa russland nach zugeben würde
dramatisch steigen also außer worten
wird nicht viel passieren daher sollte
man jetzt klar und deutlich sich am rand
machen an eine neuordnung an eine
staatliche neuordnung im konsens und
nicht einfach ihm mit phrasen um sich
laufen und sagen ja wir werden zu
erheblichen konsequenzen sind die
konsequenzen nein wir sitzen ihre am
kürzeren hebel punkt so ist das
deshalb bedeutet dass sich etwas sie
meint ich wollte sie gerade auch dazu
dieser frage abholen wir haben auch
ihren tweets gelesen sie fordern er ganz
aktiv müsse zumindest prüfen ob man der
ukraine mit waffen hilft die frage also
stünde die ukraine dann im ernstfall
alleine da wie bewerten sie das
also eine neuordnung europas befremdet
mich jetzt etwas umsatz vertiefen zu
wollen ich habe gesagt es wird keine
waffenlieferungen geben was
angriffswaffen betrifft wir haben in 17
in einer koalition wo wir das so
vereinbart haben keine waffen in
krisengebiete zu schicken gedanken
darüber machen ist die frage der
defensivwaffen das kann die frau
bierbike vorgeschlagen hat investitionen
in kliniken sein militär kliniken das
können schutzwesten helme seien
man muss natürlich defensivwaffen auch
definieren was ist defensiv und das
sollten wir tun und sollten es dann auch
nicht ausschließen eben hilfsmittel grad
auch im sanitätsbereich der ukraine
januar im zu lassen marc zimmermann aber
teilen wenn ich ganz gut sich hier ganz
kurz noch einmal unterbrechen das wird
natürlich der ukraine in diesem ganz
konkreten fall nicht helfen das ist
wunderbar die unterstützung nur
schutzhelme und das ausfliegen oder
rausfahren von verletzten soldaten das
klingt ja fast wie ein hohen werden die
tausenden panzer vor der grenze stehen
und erst recht wenn herr professor wolf
so und jetzt sagt die hat das sind
schöne worte aber da ist der ukraine
jetzt nicht geholfen im ernstfall im
absoluten ernstfall müssen die alleine
kämpfen das ist die wahrheit oder
also die ukraine ist nicht das hat auch
jens stoltenberg soweit ich weiß bei
ihnen im gespräch gesagt die ukraine ist
nicht mitglied der nato und deswegen
tritt auch kein bündnis fall ein wenn
die ukraine angegriffen würde das weiß
auch putin aber nichtsdestotrotz müssen
wir ja an der seite der ukraine stehen
man kann darüber diskutieren in der tat
mit welchen mitteln gar keine frage aber
ich sage nochmal die russen sind an der
stelle besonders verlässlich wenn es um
ihre wirtschaft geht denn auch wenn man
den gashahn zudreht richtung westen
damit werden wichtige devisen geschaffen
für russland insofern ist das durchaus
ein probates mittel es wird noch mehr
mittel geben wie ich jetzt hier gar
nicht vertiefen will aber russland muss
wissen dass der westen nicht tatenlos
zugeht und wissen sie ich sitze nicht
hier heute morgen um ein krieg
herbeizureden ich finde darf auch
vermessen sollten wir auch tödlich sein
lassen auch keine panik verbreiten
putin ist ein realpolitiker er träumt
von einer in einem sowjetischen bereich
wie er das in der vergangenheit immer
gemacht hat dann ist das nichts neues
dass die usa und russland sozusagen die
welt untereinander aufteilen und da muss
man eben grenzen ziehen und ich bin
nicht der meinung dass man hier neue
grenzen zieht oder die gerade
vorgeschlagen
plötzlich neue struktur in europa hat
sich bewährt europa in europa zu leben
in frieden und freiheit ist ein hohes
gut und deswegen müssen wir sehr genau
hinschauen was da passiert und wenn man
keinen krieg führen will dann muss es
eben andere maßnahmen geben und ich bin
sehr zuversichtlich dass es sie gibt
aber ich bin doch um konkrete punkte
hier liebevoll strack-zimmermann schätze
sie wirklich sehr aber dass sie auch
jetzt mit solch einer allgemeinen
floskeln kommen es ist doch nichts
angeben was sie vorschlagen ganz konkret
realisierbar wir machen ja sozusagen im
psychogramm von putin user suchen in
aller kürze die russische geschichte
aufzudröseln das sind alles keine
lösungen und wenn sie dann sagen die
stahlhelme oder was auch immer stützen
die chinesische krankenhäuser nein das
sind keine politischen konzepte wir
müssen mit einem politischen konzept
kommen gerade wenn sie frieden erhalten
wollen und putin ist eine realpolitiker
der strategisch denkt und es ist ihm in
den letzten 21 jahren die er 22 jahren
sogar inzwischen eher an der macht in
russland ist nicht gelungen mit allen
seiner aggressiven mitteln ist ein
aggressor gar keine frage auch hier den
westen zu einer bewegung zu bringen hat
die ukraine nicht und mit anderen worten
es muss jetzt hier ein politischer
prozess angestoßen werden insofern
vielleicht gibt es eine diplomatische
chance durch diese formel normen die
formel also mit anderen worten russland
die ukraine und deutschland und
frankreich aber es haben deutschland und
frankreich den androht enzian liegt also
man an man muss mit einem klaren
politischen konzept kommen nicht einmal
das haben sie und die außenministerin
vorgelegt auch der nato-generalsekretär
liegt und ich sehe deswegen schwarz mit
den schönen worten wird man nichts
erreicht man muss ein konzept auch in
die öffentlichkeit bringen damit auch
die westlichen politiker sagen können
wir haben alles getan um eine
militärische auseinandersetzung zu
verhindern und wenn es denn zu einer
militärischen auseinandersetzung kommen
die würde in russland natürlich im
konventionellen sinne sofort und sehr
schnell gewinnen dann aber beginnt der
zweite schritt und das ist ganz
eindeutig ein geringer kriegen und den
kann russland auch nicht gewinnen und
das war selbstverständlich auch denn er
ist nicht afghanistan der gleich
afghanistan etwas anders aussieht auch
territorialen bevölkerungspolitische
alles etwa die ukraine aber das ist die
konsequenz und da müssen wir dieses
ganzen paket an denken bitte nicht mit
allgemeinen formen 6 bei ihnen ist die
ich diese schätze vortrag zimmerwand
also erstmal freue ich mich für sie mich
schätzen ganz aber zwei karten
zurückgeben zimmermann ja klar der
kleine der kleinen flirt am morgen mir
ist wichtig und das gleiche ich jetzt
gerne auf das natürlich gesprächs
formate gefunden werden und ja auch
finden wir haben seit 2009 10
nato russland rat haben die osze wo
russland sich entsprechend auch
komischen kann was ihn wenn ich das so
sagen darf unter der unter den nägeln
brennt all diese formate sind ja wichtig
im gespräch zu bleiben und ich teile
eins wenn wir frieden haben wollen in
europa müssen wir mit den russen
sprechen aber nochmal ist kann nicht
sein dass einer feuer legt und hier
aufgefordert werden zu verhindern dass
er sich verbrennt deswegen müssen wir
gespräche führen in welchen formaten
auch immer so lange man strich schweigen
hoffentlich die waffen und in der tat
ich räume ein bei 27 eu-staaten weil 30
nato staaten wo auch geografisch die
sichtweise sehr unterschiedlich ist je
weiter man sich von der ostgrenze
entfernt sozusagen
insofern ja diese gespräche sind wichtig
da bin ich bei ihnen aber ich habe eine
rast er wissen wenn ich vor neuordnung
europas höhere sondern wir müssen auf
anderen wegen versuchen diesen frieden
zu erhalten und dafür diese neue ordnung
heißt selbstbestimmung wir haben hier
das grundlegende problem dass
selbstbestimmung verhindert und
völkerrecht so wird gestritten bei wild
life an diesem tag an dem wir insgesamt
ja mit angst mit sorge auf die lage rund
um russland rund um die ukraine schauen
und wie viel wie viel emotionen der
moment drin steckt und welche bedeutung
das haben sie an diesem streitgespräch
gerade miterleben dürfen danke herzlich
für ihren streit frau strack zimmermann
und herr professor horst und danke
vielen herzlichen dank